das wiederum ein ganzes feld einfach war
kinderlos
projekt herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video ich bin hier alleine mit lukas
zusammen ich habe mir etwas verändern
bestellt weil ich ein werbevideo dass
man gesehen hat und mit ok dieses video
heute ist kein werbung video sondern max
einfach mal austesten wir gucken uns
jetzt erst mal das video an das ich
gesehen habe was dich glücklich war und
du wirst bestimmt gleich verstehen wird
eine wippe werden das an die wand werfen
japan der und klebt überall aber ist
noch nicht brad pitt für geil auktionen
firefall du kannst dich einfach an die
wand und die abbrechen ihr seid dafür
das ipad wird nun ging an die wand junge
ganzen beamer an eine wand kleben 11
ich habe mich schnell herausfand bin
damals von verpackungen innerhalb von
diesem ding
okay das ist die karriere wollte ich hab
einen dreieck und zeigt mir bestellt das
ist macht haben gezeigt wie ein kalter
rauch macht ich hätte gern und ich würde
jetzt sagen nicht allein hätte die
zweite hinter die kamera bewegen
ich will jetzt premiere folge ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass sie bedroht sind die
wähler wieder voll kvitova und jetzt
machen wir erstmal die ersten nun den
die im video gemacht haben viel verlangt
es geht mir vor ihn und klebrig alter
als echt mega city immer einfach rappen
monate gelten jetzt mal das original ab
die im video gemacht und war ob die
dinger einfach an der wand klebt junges
bestimme myvideo angriff in meinem leben
die kugel mister ninja ja bei den
verwendeten klebeband eine tapete machen
oder an der wand die gespräche mit
irgendwie da geht gar nix klingen hier
keine deine richter liefern eine stele
könnte ich mir wirklich was erkläre ich
bin ganz zum schluss an diesem video den
test mit dem schießen wasser glatt
machen alle wissen wir also wir machen
jetzt das ding mit dem handy einfach mal
ein paar mal gemacht nun jüngste wm live
stream hat aber faktisch über den
üblichen halt irgendwann spielt ich bin
euer markt ich brauche einen stativ mehr
weil ich habe diese tollen schaidinger
gestellt probiere ich jetzt mal eine
elektrische mobilität ab und die
arbeiten handy gruppe probiert um einen
gott also auch keine klebe rückstände
oder wird auf dem handy ich weiß nicht
was wie funktioniert hat ich kann mir
das überhaupt erklären der gedachte
verrichtung von ihren babybauch nach
plan wir auch erst aber jetzt sind diese
dinge einfach gut geht weiter
what do bis kassel wird gewinn liegt in
der luft
also wie ich gezogen habe ich einfach
also du kannst das ziel wie du willst du
stehst du zu sagen aber danach nicht in
der form wie wir es jetzt machen sollte
ok sie können ihre mini game draufmachen
die meinung mit dart scheibe auf und
dann werfen wir das ding war bei dem
tier mit ihren farbigen hoffnung geiles
video sehen wir dann geht auch lukas ich
werde jetzt folgen mitmachen ist einfach
anders und verbraucht worden die der
regel auch wieder eine lange und ich
beginne mit rufnummer 110 kann mein herz
vieler unternehmen geworden und mein
letzter tag einmal getroffen vielleicht
gewinnt lukas den wollte ich wurde nur
einmal treffen und hypnotische noch mal
weiter wir machen weiter druck gemacht
werden noch irgendwelchen quatsch
dies teilte habe ich ja schon die ganze
zeit genutzt um dinge so an die wand zu
kleben oder so ich mache das jetzt mal
so richtig dreckig improviser viele
sauber zu machen war richtig schön unter
dem fernseher schrank und nehme mir so
ein bisschen staub nicht ihr wird schon
deswegen jetzt richtig staub noch ein
paar fluten von den decken
das ist ja zu sich richtig dreckig
geworden und jetzt testen wir auf der so
sauber wie im video einmal wasser drüber
laufen lassen so abwaschen im märz schon
das wird richtig sauber
[Musik]
das ding trocknen lassen ist einfach
schön wieder komplett aber die frage ist
nur wird jetzt auch wieder so gut
klingen durch beschleuniger fock nähert
man so ein bisschen in dem ich dass ein
stopp trocken mache weil eigentlich
logischerweise kommen dadurch wieder
verflogen drang das eine loch trocken
der geht besser
das teilt jetzt weitestgehend wieder
sauber ist einfach mal hinter niemand
ist zu bedenken dass hier immer alles ja
und zwar nehme ich glaube wirklich dass
laura gemacht haben nicht frisch
ich mache mir nicht voller als es noch
ein bisschen schief halten können
ich werde jetzt auch um ihr kommt mit
leuten wie brechen die rücklichter für
rationelle abläufe im alter nicht nur
kalter klarer aufbau dieses lachend weil
das schiff nicht verstehst du bist du
gegen die natur das ist ja ok aber will
eigentlich unter anderem vermittelt
reingard merkel vor ihrer reise aus
käpt'n richtigkeit hineingeschüttet
bezügen für beides eingebungen um fallen
sollte
[Musik]
dafür gefällt einfach mag liegt in der
luft
baltrum mittlerweile wie kann das sein
es gibt auch entwickeln unglaublich
kraft also wollen wir nicht erlernt
vor allem geringe ich hab die affäre
entwicklern wären gesehen und falls ihr
die zufällig auf dem deutlich bestellt
es nicht
ich habe keine werden bestellt und die
ihnen diese instagram für adidas
beworben hat hat irgendwie 0,5 von zehn
gewinner online bewertungen bei die
anscheinend wird weil die betrüger sind
und einfach die videos klauen von
anderen führen also mit anderen worten
wer etwas suchen wollt dann tut auch
enden aber ich mich okay leute also was
kann ich dazu sagen für wichtige flash
dass das missioniert und wie heftig
diese teile sind in dem sie eine
klappleiter nächsten mal wieder machst
du bist ein tür